welcome all and a special welcome of  course to our honorees where are you  guys sitting raise your hand shamelessly  excellent congratulations guys and gals  I hope you enjoy many more nights like  this one or that at least you enjoy them  as much as writers are able to enjoy  anything with a combination of delight  satisfaction and something that  initially feels like humility but that  quickly is recognized to be  self-loathing enjoy all right  Anton Yelchin was a great supporter of  these libraries of the Nicholl  fellowship winners and he participated  in our very first one in fact the Julie  Linda producer that year reminded me  that Anton was the first actor to  volunteer for it he know very well what  a screenplay contributes to a movie he  brought to the reading not only his  talent his charisma and his warmth his  humor but also his cooperative spirit  this evening is dedicated to him